hey I'm Curtin Davina and this is
remember one the show about old stories
in gaming history told with new
perspectives and today we're looking at
how the Xbox one went from having quite
possibly the worst sales pitch in gaming
history to swooning its way into our
hearts as it stands today the Xbox one
has a lot to love
it's got game pass 600 backwards
compatible games the adaptive controller
the smart delivery initiative for Xbox
series X and an impressive roster of
creative developers joining the Xbox
family it's kind of hard not to love
what the console has to offer which is
why it's kind of crazy to think that it
started with none of those things
[Music]
so let's start at the beginning the
pitch seven years back this man took the
stage to reveal what he claimed would be
the all-in-one entertainment system good
morning everyone
his name is Don Mattrick and he was the
president of Xbox what he presented that
day maybe wasn't exactly what people
were hoping for Xbox watch TV and with
that simple command I'm watching live TV
this is tomorrow Hussein and back in
2013 he was writing a lot of news on
this I was excited to see what how they
were gonna build on the success of the
Xbox because the Xbox 360 gave us things
that we weren't used to having in the
console space online gaming kind of
connectivity with other people
achievements those are kind of things
that either were new or only available
to PC players the excitement going into
how they would build on that and evolve
that for a new generation of gaming and
consoles was overwhelming is palpable at
the time Xbox was the one to watch at
the time and then I remember when the
announcement happened it was like
confusing and deflating in a huge way we
believe we can evolve what you love to
make it decidedly better and deliver
breakthrough innovations like you've
never seen before all new experiences
groundbreaking technology even more
innovation of an ambitious vision for
Xbox one what the single device could
provide all your entertainment all of
your entertainment comes alive in one
place of the hour-long reveal about 15
minutes of it were actually dedicated to
video games the rest of it was about
watching TV even when they announced the
game quantum break it was pitched as a
weird TV show video game hybrid thing
they didn't make an announcement about
halo thank you that they were making a
TV show based off of it which still
hasn't happened I think it's being made
right they're producing that Microsoft
message was incredibly mixed unclear and
not at all what people expected or
wanted they came in with very
entertainment focused angle to it and
because of that they were already on the
backfoot let's do it again go to
Internet Explorer oh nice watch TV now
if there's one thing clear from that
reveal is that us the people who play
games the people who would have bought
that system to play them were no longer
the core focus and unfortunately that
was only half the problem leading up to
the system's reveal a bunch of rumor
starts sweeping headlines that sent a
lot of us into a panic stuff like it
requiring an always online connection a
lack of backwards compatibility and a
restriction unused games and all of
those rumors were true so the three main
hurdles that Microsoft screwed up
clearing were always online connectivity
used games and then backwards
compatibility so always online
connectivity
I felt anti-consumer these days it's
commonplace and almost a necessity
because it the way it intersected always
online connectivity intersected with
things like access to your games and
access to your accounts the Xbox one
always needed to have online
connectivity and if it didn't have
online connectivity it was basically a
cement brick underneath your TV whoever
or not that is the case the problem was
that was the thing that most people took
away from it that's the thing that
wasn't the case but Xbox did such a bad
job of explaining these boundaries that
that's how a lot of people felt so it
didn't always have to be online but
instead once every 24 hours and say
you're playing on a friend system logged
in under your account will then know to
have to check once every hour or maybe
you didn't have the luxury of an
internet connection or were in the army
well the answer to that was to play an
Xbox 360 fortunately we have a product
for people who aren't able to get some
form of connectivity it's called xbox
360 right so stick with 360 that's your
message if you know well oh my gosh if
you have zero access to the inner
that is an offline device the second
rumor that ended up being true was
backwards-compatibility so Don Mattrick
crunched some numbers and discovered
that 5% of players used a new system to
play old games so if we're going off 360
sales that would mean of the 80 million
people who bought a 360 4 million of
them used it to play old games and then
he followed that up with if you're
backwards compatible then you're really
backwards it was a big deal because of
the success Microsoft had with the 360
so the 360 was like the procession to
before it the de-facto console of choice
for a lot of people that means all the
biggest franchises
all the games that you probably love
playing and owned were on the 360 and
because it wasn't immediately clear it
wasn't immediately possible that you
could play all those games on the Xbox
one that meant people were locked out of
so much of the content they had spent
their money on that they were invested
in and that they were still playing
because the 360 was an online console so
years after their releases people are
still playing gears people are still
playing card people are still playing
various other online games and the fact
that that wasn't a clear line was being
drawn in the sand and Microsoft was
saying all that money you spent and all
that time your point is now done away
with that was a problem that was a huge
problem for them lastly there is lending
and reselling games which is kind of a
doozy so to properly explain this I will
be using a number of props including my
cat say I wanted to give my copy of
Deadly Premonition to my cat Megatron in
order for her to play this game her and
I would have to be friends on Xbox Live
for a total of 30 days apparently she's
not too happy about that so now say
Megatron wants the lone Deadly
Premonition
to her best friend BJ blaskowitz
unfortunately for BJ there is a one-time
transfer between games so he wouldn't
even be able to play at all again
Megatron did not seem to like that so
what does this mean for reselling games
to explain that I'm gonna bring in
Godzilla
now Godzilla represents the publisher in
this case
specifically to Deadly Premonition I
also have jolly Jim who represents the
retailer Godzilla holds the right as to
whether or not deadly premonition is
even resellable let's say it is and I
want to sell this game to Chow agent
Godzilla also has the right to say yo
jolly Jim you owe me money if you want
to resell this game which would ensure
less than the value of deadly
premonition that means they would have
to make a profit somehow which would
give me less money if I wanted to resell
the game and then on top of all that
Godzilla can just choose to make the
game unsure Bowl to anyone else at all
this sounds like a lot that's because it
is and it all felt like the fine print
at the end of a contract you didn't even
want to sign the first place because all
you wanted to do was play the video
games use gaming was and still is a huge
part of the way people consumed games
games are expensive they come out very
very frequently and for a lot of people
the only way they can stay up-to-date
with games is to buy one trade it in and
use some of that money to buy another
one people on the gaming and press and
fansite what they were hearing was you
won't be able to play the games that you
want to play without shelling out a lot
of money and it goes back to that
feeling of Microsoft was trying to rip
away how people experience games and
played games from the player and I
haven't even brought up the Kinect yet
but in short it was a requirement for
this dude whether you liked it or not
all of which put this at 499 dollars
between its restrictive barriers its
lack of focus on games that Kinect being
required and its price tag is all-in-one
entertainment system started to feel
like it was for no one and of course
Sony took this time to revel in its
competitors controversies with the
announcement of the PlayStation 4 I'm
very proud to announce that PlayStation
4 will be available at 399 dollars
the playstation 4 had no online
requirement no game sharing restrictions
no use game restrictions and it was $100
cheaper this is how you share your games
on ps4 thanks these consoles weren't
even out yet but Sony had already taken
the lead in just a matter of a couple
weeks Xbox did backpedal on both online
requirements and game sharing
requirements but the damage had been
done and a lot of us were no longer
listening which brings us to the next
segment the turning of the tides this is
Phil Spencer and in 2013 he became the
new president of Xbox taking the place
of Don Mattrick and it was during this
time that things just started to turn
around this guy was through and through
a video game fan he's been at the
company for a really long time and has
been pushing through you know different
initiatives but now he was in a position
of power and influence he was top of the
Xbox food chain I think a lot of people
feel I would attribute Phil Spencer's
rise to the top of Microsoft and Xbox as
a key turning point for that company
first order of business Kinect is out
making this thing three hundred and
ninety-nine dollars next up is backwards
compatibility making games like Deadly
Premonition
playable in the original form sneak King
still isn't in there but it's okay it's
fine
then in 2017 game pass happen which made
hundreds of games both old and
completely new available to just
download it on your system for a
reasonable monthly fee then the adaptive
controller came along which made this
medium more available to a broader
demographic who otherwise could
experience these games as easily and
recently with the announcement of its
new console Xbox series X several of the
games you purchase for Xbox one will be
available on the Xbox series X with no
additional fee and this is called smart
delivery
now over the past seven years Xbox has
completely flipped its identity around
and nothing better demonstrates that
than its presence at e3 in 2018 it was
nothing but an onslaught of game after
game after game reveal then in 2019 was
another unrelenting showcase of games
buying up more creative and interesting
Studios like Double Fine a big ol step
in the direction of cloud gaming and
Keanu Reeves
even though Xbox has managed to turn the
ship around
it hasn't truly bounced back from that
initial sales pitch at least none sales
PlayStation 4 has sold more than double
the Xbox one but in mind share the
perception of Xbox especially my own is
entirely different I didn't even get an
Xbox one until 2018 because of stuff
like game pass and backwards
compatibility and through some very hard
lessons Xbox is in a stronger position
now with a new generation on the way
which is very telling from the Xbox
series X reveal which was only focused
on games not watching TV not some
connecting gimmick so while a lot of us
still have a bad taste our mouths from
the Xbox ones launch it's hard not to
applaud them for bringing it back to the
core focus of this entire medium the
players
hey thanks for watching this episode of
remember-when now don't worry I am
working on a Playstation equivalent to
this so be on the lookout for that
sometime in the near future also if you
want to watch all the previous episodes
of remember-when check out the playlist
link in the description below also
lastly you could bug me on Twitter if
you'd like at curt underscore in Davina
I think that's all I got
be well until next time see ya